foreign
let's go to Samantha the home play some
Alice in Chains in Seattle Washington
what's up Samantha
hi Dr D
um nothing much how are you nothing much
Hey listen uh we can have a moment here
but this weekend my Astros defeated your
Seattle team they did but that was a
really good game you know it was I was
actually at a wedding reception I'm like
we've now had two baseball games it was
a masterpiece that's what my daughter
she's like nine plus nine we had two
baseball games dad and I was I was more
impressed with her math than I was any
of those teams hitting so well done well
done Mariners y'all represented Seattle
well all right so what's up
um so this is a follow-up call from
about a year ago
I came to give you a heads up
Oh it sounded like
no bring it bring it let's do it either
follow-up calls are usually or one of
two things things have gotten incredible
and I got a new new question or
things have driven off into the ditch
and often to the ditch okay what
happened what's going on
a year ago I called you about my brother
who
um was using methamphetamine for several
years just kind of how to have healthy
boundaries but still have him in my life
and that was a really helpful call but
now things have changed to where I do
not want him in my life but
I'm having a tough time handling that
what happened
um
um
sorry don't be sorry
I'm good take a minute take a minute
he was convicted of a crime uh where he
thankfully it was a detective but it was
um attempting luring of a minor and
um I have two young girls I have a two
and a three-year-old and
I just can't have them in my life and so
um
I
I mean maybe it was a mistake maybe it
wasn't but I got a hold of all the
online Communications and read through
them because you know my mom and his
girlfriend were like it's not that bad
it's not you know oh this is all a setup
and I'm like I I don't believe you guys
and then
so I've seen it for myself and I know
intuitively in my head this is not a
person I can have around my family but
hold on
somebody along the way possibly your mom
communicated to you
that your body was not to be trusted
I want you to hold on to that sentence
you just you just put forth and put a
period at the end of it before you get
to the butt
intuitively I know this is a person I do
not want around my kids period
okay your body is worth being believed
okay
yes and I have a little girl too and I'm
right there with you
and so I guess I just
I go through like bouts of anger and
rage and then like deep sadness yep and
I mean it's kind of getting cyclical at
this point that my husband's like man
it's
like what's going on in your head and
I'm like my brother I'm sad
um and then I keep reminding myself that
my brother's someone that hurts children
because I'm also a prosecutor and I know
the first time you get caught it's not
the first time so it's
really hard for me to grieve this loss
of this whole family that I had
envisioned
um with his daughters and my fans so
it's just
I don't know how to deal with the anger
and the rage and then the deep sadness
or I don't know maybe if I'm just right
where I'm supposed to be you're you are
right where you're supposed to be
and I hate to tell you that because
where you are is really painful right
yeah yeah
and you're a prosecutor they didn't talk
about this part in law school the part
where you just sit in it and it hurts
yeah because even behind it all and
behind all the pain the drug use and all
that it's your brother man
and behind all of that
to him huh do I do I
I don't know do I tell him this is it
we're done uh
you know it's just kind of he's still
you know sitting in jail awaiting
sentencing so it
here's the thing do I write him a letter
uh I would I'd probably write him
several and I probably wouldn't send the
first two or three or four I wrote
but when you're processing a rage and
you're processing grief I want you to
think of it like this you're in your
house
and your smoke alarms going off so loud
and you just need to get your bearings
right so you can focus on where the fire
is
okay and so when you write that thing
down let it rip man
it's probably not even going to be
coherent and if it is it's going to be
rageful and ultimately not helpful
except that it gets your rage out of
your body onto paper and you can look at
it and you can re-read it and you can
say things like I don't hate you and
wish you hope you die
and right you see you begin to parse it
apart and you begin to demand evidence
from it which parts of these are true
you can never be around my kids you've
burned that bridge to the ground and
that's a choice you made not me that's a
choice you made right so you can begin
to parse that stuff out but right now it
just feels like everything's on fire
and it should be man your brother hurts
kids you know you know what I mean like
it it it should be
have you entered into surrealville
where you've thought about it so much
and gotten so mad and had so many
conversations that it almost becomes
distant like it's not real anymore
yeah so I do keep telling Mike because
time has gone on this happened the last
like you know the initial arresting was
about a year ago and
so because time passed you kind of
forget and so then I have to remind
myself you know especially now that he's
sober in jail and he sounds different
and he's going to get all these
different treatments but I'm like I mean
honestly maybe this sounds bad but in my
head I'm like I wish you would have
killed someone I could handle you having
killed someone easier than you hurting a
child and so
I'm like it doesn't really matter what
level of therapy you achieve
I can't have you in my life and that's
just really hard I mean that's so final
it is and
um
he made that choice not you
you put up a boundary in response to his
choices but he has to own the choice he
made
and you're just doing the next logical
right thing
that happens to hurt and here's a deeper
hurt
at some point your parents are going to
have to choose him or you and it sounds
like right now they're choosing him
or he's become their cause of him or his
their guilt and shame over how whatever
happened the addiction to this to the to
the solicitation of minor they're taking
all of that on their shoulders and so
they are so thrilled by every new moment
of sobriety and every new chip and every
new therapeutic intervention because all
of those are a road back to them feeling
less burden
and that's not what this is about
this is about a guy who hurts girls
little kids
and you'll be damned if it's going to be
one of yours
right
yeah
I'm sorry
I'm sorry that thanksgivings will look
different and Christmases will look
different and you'll be guilted for the
next X number of years and here's the
other thing these things have dominoes
and there may come a moment when you
gotta you gotta remove your parents out
of that conversation
or another brother or sister or you have
to block his girlfriend
there are very very few shoulds and have
to's during grief
grief as Kessler says is like a
fingerprint it's Unique to everybody and
so when your husband says hey what's
going on in your head today just say I'm
heartbroken
I'm angry today
and the shoulds are you have to eat and
you gotta sleep and you got to have
human contact and you got to move your
body right you got to do those things to
keep your body functioning so that you
have an opportunity to be well down the
road but right now is at that time
foreign
how long is he going to go away for
it's because he doesn't have a record
um but he doesn't get sentenced till the
21st what do you think it's going to be
more worried about
um probably more around
probably like the two-year Mark okay
I'm not so worried about the in custody
part I'm worried about what you just
talked about the aftermath when everyone
sees but he's getting better and you
know I'm a Christ lover and you know I'm
all about Redemption but I it's not at
the expense of my family and I'm I'm All
About Redemption and I'm also all about
not getting bit twice
and redemption in this case might be
that you meet him for coffee
redemption in this case might be that um
uh
you know
you you show up to your mom's birthday
party by yourself
because they choose who they're going to
invite and when they say we just want to
see the grandkids you say great
as long as there's not a convicted child
um
uh abuser or child solicitor here then
the kids are welcome here that's a
choice y'all make
and is here a matter of fact I'm making
it that's the goal here
it's just very simple
yes I'm gonna be around you guys
do what
I have one but my parents are divorced
one parent understands and the other
doesn't
and the longer you try you might just
have to set a boundary yeah yeah the
longer you try to convince that other
person the more exhausted and burned out
you're gonna get
this isn't a conversation it's not
yeah trust your body this isn't a
conversation about more data this isn't
a conversation about more facts or more
oh yeah what about this what about
this is somebody's son
and they're choosing to
focus on things
that you're not focusing on and you're
choosing to focus on things that are not
funny like this isn't a matter of I just
need to convince you or argue argue my
position so well that you change your
mind it's never going to happen
so it's just stating boundaries clear
yeah if you choose to have him come over
then you're just choosing for your
grandkids not to be here you're probably
choosing for me not to be here for a few
years but
you're for sure choosing not to see your
grandkids that's all
simple matter of fact and then you go
home and You Weep bitterly because this
isn't how it's supposed to be
our family members aren't supposed to
hurt kids
our parents are supposed to look at
situations no matter how painful they
are and do the right thing
and be honest and be whole
you can already imagine the future
conversations you're going to have with
your own daughters about your brother
which are scary you already know part of
my brothers is me
if he's capable of right man and then
you get on that rabbit hole
this is grief this is grief
the greatest gift you can give to your
husband is to be honest and open and
explain it to him here's what I feel
here's what I'm working on I'm going to
give you permission to talk into my life
if if you see me not not doing okay
but also be gentle and curious with me
don't judge me I'm working through it I
want things to be different and right
now they're just not
so sorry Sam so so sorry golly
thank you for loving your baby girls
they are gr they are they are so lucky
to have you as their mom